hello welcome to my living room come on
in
if this is our favorite place our most
comfortable couch we fight about who
gets to sit here
when they said well my mother painted
this picture when I was around 10 or 12
years old it hung in my room and now
I've brought it to my house almost all
the paintings were done by my
mother-in-law or my mother they're both
very talented would you like to tell
them about this picture go ahead I made
it my son inherited his artistic skills
from his grandmother's mama this over it
this is those abilities
my mother also painted this box for me
so I'd have a place to keep all my
valuable possessions now it's here at
our house too and I keep both my and my
kids things in it she made it for me
when I was very young that's why it's
decorated with things i liked then
things like baseballs teddy bears stuff
like that will stir with each other
thanks for stopping by this is our home
and I hope you come back to Chiapas soon
save up my kids